back in the US Capitol another day of
testimony from the president's former
attorney and fixer today's session
unlike wednesday's was held in private
but there has been a very public
reaction by Republicans to some of
Michael Cohen's statements yesterday
chief intelligence correspondent
Catherine Harridge is live tonight on
Capitol Hill
good evening Catherine thank you Brennan
good evening the testimony concluded
within the last hour with Cohen making a
brief public statement but he showed no
questions on the criminal referral as I
said I'm committed to telling the truth
the criminal referral to Attorney
General William bar from to house
Republicans alleges Michael Cohen
perjured himself during Wednesday's
public testimony I did not want to go to
the White House I was offered jobs the
referral quotes prosecutors in the
Southern District of New York where
Cohen pled guilty to bank and tax fraud
as well as lying quote during and after
the campaign Cohen privately told
friends and colleagues including in
cease text messages that he expected to
be given a prominent role and title in
the new administration Cohen's attorney
Lanny Davis called the referral quote
baseless and driven by quote to
pro-trump committee members but then
there's Cohen CNN interview four days
after the 2016 election absolutely a
chance is gonna ask certainly would you
go 100 percent there was other push back
on Twitter WikiLeaks said his editor
never spoke to political operative Roger
stone about hacked Democratic emails as
Cohen testified mr. stone told mr. Trump
that he had just gotten off the phone
with Julian Assange there would be a
massive dump of emails that would damage
Hillary Clinton's campaign the
president's lawyer Rudy Giuliani said
Cohen's testimony that he waived
attorney-client privileges quote
provably faults mr. Trump repeated his
criticism of his former lawyer and
so-called fixer he said no collusion
with the Russian hoax
and I said I wonder why he didn't just
lie about that do like he did about
everything else the hearing also
underscored an appearance shift by
Democrats away from Russia collusion to
allege fraudulent business practices by
Trump did the president ever provide
inflated assets to an insurance company
yes and where would the committee find
more information on this do you think we
need to
view his financial statements and his
tax returns in order to compare them yes
and you'd find it at the Trump org
Republicans to acknowledge the Democrats
appearance shift in strategy while
dismissing suggestions the president
faces further legal and political
trouble the impeachment cupboard is bare
and I think the focus is shifting to
financial crime the Democratic chairman
of the House Intelligence Committee will
recall Cohen March 6 for more clothes
testimony he was fully cooperative and
answered all of our questions and you
know this has obviously been an
excruciating time for him and Schiff
announced another public hearing for
March 14th with a russian-born one-time
Trump business associate Felix cedar who
worked with Cohen to market the 2016
Moscow Trump real estate project as you
know Brett that project never came
through catherine herridge live on
Capitol Hill all Catherine thanks